everyone's talking about reboots where
would Harold and Kumar be today today I
married and still doing weeded married
with children and stepping out onto the
patio yeah having a good time yeah John
show dishing on what his character
Harold and sidekick Kumar would be up to
now while promoting his new dark comedy
The Oath a political film about a
holiday dinner turned violent clearly
things take a turn in this film at
Thanksgiving when you're having your
holidays have you ever had one of those
scenarios where things took a turn for
the worse yeah I mean I do try and avoid
talking politics with my parents but I
can't help it sometimes and we get it it
gets crazy but I try to remember that
they're good people and we all are
trying to figure out what's best for the
country but we differ lit a copy of the
O's on fire and throw some constituents
oh that is so not illegal if we had a
real life Oh would you sign it a written
allegiance to our President or our
country I would not because I would say
you don't have the right to ask me to do
that not that I don't feel loyalty to
this country because I really do but I
don't I would decline based upon that
times have also changed a lot for you I
know we had the movement of starring
John Cho going and now we are seeing
crazy rich Asians - all the boys I've
loved before just more leading roles for
the Asian American community is that
does that feel like a long time coming
or how far do we have to go there
I mean it's it's a I think my answer is
twofold I mean on the one hand I'm
really really encouraged
and I think it's a beautiful thing and
the thing that I'm most happy about is
people expressing themselves online
wherever the activism that's taking
place and people just sort of being
heard and saying this is what we like
this is what we'd like more of that on
the other hand I do feel like even
though there's more visibility what I
want are more quality roles you know
like so we can in the discussion about
the quantity of roles I don't want to
lose the discussion about the quality
role so I want to keep pushing on that
front too would you your dream roll your
bucket list role would it be something
that's a biopic or is it something that
is creative what do you have in mind for
a leading role I always said I'd love to
do a Shakespeare on screen I think that
would be fun
[Music]